what do you guys think the percent
chance is uh
by the end of the weekend that we hit a
new all-time high i i think you book it
book it it's done okay book it oh
i don't trade yeah financial yeah but
this is not terms and conditions
i think that there is more than an 80
chance by the end of the weekend we hit
a new all-time high and it's driven by
three things one once we broke through
58 000
it's likely then that there's nothing
else there's no more resistance till the
new all-time high the second thing is
you can feel that the sentiment online
has shifted from one that was super
bearish to now it's very bullish and you
can start to see that uh in the way that
people are tweeting and talking about it
etc people are coming out of the
woodwork to go talk on national
television now like the whole game's
being played the third thing is that you
can see on chain that we are starting to
see a little bit of large holders they
started to sell just a little bit of
their holdings which means that they
think that we're starting to move
upwards and they'll sell into the
strength uh and then actually one other
thing is you can look and see on the
various order books that there's a ton
of buy support coming in and so when you
add up those factors it's not a
guarantee but over 80 confidence by the
end of the week and we hit an all-time
high
why are you smiling because i'm locked
and loaded
ready to go
that would be nice
yeah it's just um it's one of these
things by the way if it's not right i'm
not going to do anything different again
i don't i don't trade on any of this
stuff but like if you just said to me
okay you have to make a choice is it or
is it not like over 80 but still it's 20
likely that it doesn't happen so if we
come back on monday and like oh it
hasn't happened yet and it waits till
the end of that week oh i was off by
four or five days like okay yeah it
doesn't change any long-term thinking at
all but i just get a little better mood
you know i like i don't like hearing the
the bears talk all day on twitter i
gotta stop i like i gotta stop watching
the price dude i look at it every day
knowing that i'm not going to do
anything even with the price why do you
do that why do you do that why do i look
at the price yeah every day multiple
times a day multiple times
all day long ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen welcome to an
example of what not to do nah i look at
it but i know that no matter what it
could go down by 20 or it could go up by
20 i'm still not going to do anything
the only thing i'll even probably be
incentivized to do is if it went down a
significant amount i'd probably try to
buy more yeah so you have long-term
conviction but you're just interested in
this yeah i'm just interested it's like
a dopamine hit for you yeah and she's
like ooh why not
you guys gonna tell me you guys gonna
stand here sit here and tell me you
don't look at the price every day i look
at the price probably
one
maybe two times a day
twice what when you wake up like in the
morning and in the afternoon or night
yeah okay how many that's basically what
i do when i wake up i look at it uh and
then um i pretty much the only other
time i'll look at it is if uh i see a
bunch of people tweeting about something
and then i'll be like oh something's
going on and i'll go check yeah cause
it's like you're missing the contacts
right i don't have a live stream of the
price like on my on my tv i don't know
bro you said it was going like this you
were looking at it like that bang bang
we just hit 1.5 k likes i also think
like the volatility has been lessened a
lot over the last few months so there
was a period of time where we weren't
really moving joe do not get a little to
sleep baby do not get low ready to go
the rocket john's talking about the
rocket going to the moon is i'm ready i
told you locked and loaded
bitcoin went from 64 000 drop down to 30
thousand dollars and now it's back at 57
58 000 and people are acting like it's
at 32. like the whole world is asleep
and that's what you need the whole world
is asleep
and it just creeps out
quiet
and then for the next three months you
ain't going to be able to sleep listen
that's the quietest almost 2x in all of
financial markets from 30 000 almost 60
000
and literally we didn't make a peep
ain't nobody wake up they're all still
asleep they got their pajamas on they're
tucked in a bit way at night every
single wall street banker that doesn't
have any bitcoin is like oh that stupid
thing it's back at 32. oh [ __ ] it's that
made up 60. you made a good point i
i disagree with most of that what do you
do you think it's been dead quiet
bro
go on the street right now ask people
what bitcoin's price is nobody thinks
that 60k that's because half the people
in america don't even know what bitcoin
is still okay they're asleep next so it
might be great but if a stock doubles in
price ain't no one talking about it on
youtube
i talk to investors all day long and
there are multiple investors that i've
talked to this week who had no clue that
bitcoin was almost at sixty thousand
dollars
the same number of people talking about
what it wouldn't be anymore number of
people talking about tesla or if amazon
doubled in price people might talk about
it but if you're involved in the world
you're involved in the world anyways
it's not like you're just going to be
like oh like would you guys say
valentine's day tesla doubled right now
and it happened in a 90-day period
nobody would shut up about it yeah but
you're picking an asset that's very
it's very social driven
okay amazon doubled no one would stop
talking about it
if peloton double dude what are you what
are you doing wait wait what do you talk
about all day huh what are you talking
about
[Laughter]
you talk about bitcoin all day and so
does everyone else on the internet
everyone knows where it's at we're going
to the